vous aviez sa déclaration qui se frotte
is france quand je m'appelle blanc oh
non je le fus qu'elle s'allonger pas le
clap céder sa main étant le nous a peu
de serge tu l'as vu voilà ces sacs quoi
ça celui ci
ces chats moi je sais tu m'as dit déjà
dit avant de venir à udine ai dit tu vas
me laisser parler quand même temps dit
il m'a dit ça tu vas te taire quand même
la perfide albion
j'ai eu mes mauldin sanction par l'eau
parle-nous un peu de tout à l'égout et
du cop bad cop encore il n'est pas mon
épouse
tu vois pas pourquoi ils prennent crédit
pour quelque chose qui n'a jamais fait
écoute il faut toujours le faire mais
mes cousines elle refuse de donner ses
empreintes si oui je vois tu vois pas
pourquoi il faut même pas lundi souffre
un voleur des formulaires
[Musique]